china has been under pressure to prove
the whereabouts of tennis star pang
schwein
now these videos have been released
which appear to show pang having dinner
with her coach and friends
the editor-in-chief of chinese newspaper
the global times posted the video on his
twitter account xu xing says they were
filmed on saturday
and on sunday this video was posted on
the popular chinese social media site
weibo by the organizers of a tennis
tournament
the former tennis doubles world champion
hasn't been seen since november the
second
that's when she accused a former chinese
government official of sexual abuse the
authorities probably would like to give
the impression that penguin
is still active that she lives normally
in china
but i think the general speculation is
that she probably has been taken away by
the authorities for holiday somewhere in
a remote place to prevent her from
talking to the media or
continue to continue to tell her stories
the women's tennis association says the
videos are not enough and don't show
proof of peng's well-being the world's
top tennis body has threatened to pull
tournaments out of china
and the international olympic committee
says it's working with the women's
tennis association to help establish
pang's safety the united nations has
called for a fully transparent
investigation while the white house has
also added its voice we are deeply
concerned by reports that pengshui
appears to be missing after accusing a
former prc senior official of sexual
assault we join in the calls for prc
authorities to provide independent and
verifiable proof of her whereabouts and
that she is safe
tennis stars including serena williams
and novak djokovic have also voiced
concern for her safety
and the chinese government spokesman
says it's not a diplomatic issue
but it's already become one
laura about a manly al jazeera